[Music]
[Music]
hey folks welcome back to the Dark Horse
podcast livestream number 24 Q and a
section where we will answer your Q's
with our A's to the best of our ability
ok shall we get right to it I start with
something thank you for reminding me yes
there is a certain amount of bad
behavior in the chat and comments and I
know that this is standard for YouTube I
also know that for Heather and me this
has been a lot less terrible than it is
on most other channels so thank you for
being disciplined and I know that as the
channel grows this is going to be a
problem as new people show up and they
don't realize that there's actually a
community spirit around here and in any
case to the extent that you can figure
out ways to disincentivize that behavior
please do and to the extent that there
are numskulls who want to come into the
chat and do anything they can to start a
race war or whatever else you're trying
to do please don't this is very serious
no matter what side of the political
spectrum you may be on we are in a very
difficult moment in history a moment
when there's so much gasoline and tinder
around that one numbskull might be able
to set the whole thing a flame and it
would be a terrible shame if we're here
on this channel so please don't do it
alright get to the Q's and A's all right
we're gonna start as always many many
good questions I've only looked at a few
of them but we're gonna start with a
question that has been asked twice
previously which we didn't get to twice
so here we go are you at all concerned
that growing global tensions between the
USA and China are leading us to an
inevitable Cold War and quite possibly
an actual hot war in the near future
where the legacy superpower USA faces
off against the latest up-and-comer
China yes in fact I'm not even sure that
the political discord that we find
ourselves running into is not being
seeded or amplified by some of our
enemies who have recognized
that we have set ourselves up for
failure and that if they stir the pot at
this moment we may well do ourselves in
and save them the trouble
so yeah it's the new crypto warfare it's
the new crypto warfare and we would be
very wise that the hardest thing is you
don't see this system broken as it is is
doing a tremendous amount of work that
you don't notice the part that functions
is not visible and you'll note you'll
detect it when it's gone so we all have
an interest in preserving this structure
the idea that this is the moment that
we're gonna go after George Washington
of all people is so absurd and so
dangerous we have to recognize what it
is that unites us and what it is that
separates us and let's do something
about that latter part but tearing apart
the former part is an act of purest
insanity and can I just remind those who
may not remember that you say this as
someone who and this is true for me too
who sees neither of the major party
candidates as viable solutions to the
problems that we have in part because
put aside Trump for the moment but why
isn't Biden a viable solution he's you
know he's basically giving us the bush
line you know put aside his likely
mental incompetence but he's giving us
the sort of bush to line bush one-line
to stay the course we're on right stay
the course and you have been arguing for
decades that the many parts of the
course are broken so you it is not that
you think that everything is fine this
is not a you know a volte area a Candide
like universe in which everything is
going along just fine but the
fundamentals of the system which are
working are invisible to those who are
complaining that the entire thing must
be burned down and it is very like
quitting smoking
the fact is yeah this is a terrible time
to have to figure out what to do but it
keeps getting worse
so as bad as it is now to have to figure
out how to rescue ourselves from two non
viable candidates you don't want it to
be worse and it is not the fault of
people who have been telling you this
election after election it's not our
fault the fact that you're finally
listening that is not on us yeah and I
guess one just one more thing about this
thinking about the distinction between
cold war in hot war which made a lot of
sense I think it's a distinction to make
up through the late 80s or so when the
Cold War nominally ended but the the
crypto war that can go on a war of
information that is now possible at all
moments in all places actually doesn't
care if the war is also otherwise cold
or hot so that will continue regardless
and that means that the boundaries
between these things are even harder to
determine yeah actually good point let
me add one thing to it hmm this is a new
thought I reserve the right to go back
and fix it yeah you've got cold Wars and
hot Wars you've got something we call
terrorism terrorism is yeah the
hijacking of your fight-or-flight reflex
to get you to harm yourself an enemy
that can't harm you uses terror to get
you to harm yourself same way that it
might get your immune system to
compromise you if it can't outright hurt
you this cyber meddling the cyber
meddling in our ability to think
straight is not terror it's not that you
go on Twitter and are terrified into
hurting yourself but it's like it's like
they drugged us whoever it is that feeds
bad information into that system is
basically bewildering us so that we will
fall off a cliff or fall down the stairs
or something like that and the fact is
the first thing to do is recognize
something doesn't want us to see clearly
there's organic noise and then there is
amplified noise your enemy might only
have to get you confused enough to to
get yourself into a civil war for
example that you can't afford and that
would do their bidding they won't fight
you they'll have you fight you hmm
so ya know there's a lot more here with
regard to what what emotions are being
played it's not terror as you say but is
it you know creating such slothfulness
and complacency that you don't bother to
get up and at the point that you do
you're so outraged at what you have been
led to believe that you then spill into
the streets and destroy statues of
George Washington you know is is there
is there no middle ground left possible
when it's this kind of information war
yep yeah okay next question different
neighborhoods and cultures have
different levels of noise at night
for instance loud music mufflers that
roar like lions buy homes poor sleep
lowers IQ and impulse control can sleep
disturbances from loud noises affect
academic and economic gaps are there
solutions it's a really good question
it's a great question that includes so
much of the information you need in an
exam almost answers itself but yeah the
thing is um go to the rich neighborhood
you'll see what's good we know it's not
a secret yeah right we can talk all we
want about you know GMOs are just a
modification like humans have been doing
for thousands of years this garbage they
eat organic food in the rich
neighborhood and you can't afford him
the poor neighborhood you may not even
be able to source it so yeah the good
neighborhood is quieter it has better
schools it has higher quality food it
has a smaller space yeah I wake up to
birdsong not car horns and that you know
that's less true in in dense urban
centers and you know it is what it is
one of the reasons that cities like New
York were actually like we're actually
melting pots and did actually experience
you know I think I think reductions in
racism because people were really living
side-by-side and not just across the you
know standard demographics were expected
to talk about today along race lines but
about socio-economic lines but you know
in most cities and certainly as soon as
you get out of the city center they're
very stratified they are and even in New
York you know if you if you're really
wealthy you live by the park and so one
side of your building looks out on a
quieter nicer space so anyway yes it's
not we can't compare between cities
necessarily but we know what works we
know what's harmful and we externalize
all of this harm onto people who are not
politically powerful enough to prevent
it and so yes the answer to your
question is there are solutions and they
involve confronting what it is that
actually causes well-being and
opportunity to be hoarded in some parts
of town and excluded from others and
there ain't no way of getting
around its that it you know we either
confronted or it's the French Revolution
they're worse ya know and I guess again
this this could warrant many many hours
of conversation but usually when we talk
about pollution and you until 20 years
ago whenever you heard talk about
pollution it was about particulate
matter you know actual you know things
that could lodge in you and cause I
their physical or chemical or biological
damage but noise pollution and light
pollution are real these are not just
made-up fictions by the liberal
chattering academic glasses this is this
is absolutely 100% real and having
access to true darkness at night and
true silence when you choose to have it
are luxuries that were not luxuries but
expectations of human existence for most
of humanity's existence on the planet
and the lack of ability to procure those
things for a large proportion of people
is staggeringly bad yeah I would say
there's also some kind of pollution that
I don't think has a name
it's like reality pollution you know if
you go to certain neighborhoods you'll
find you know the billboards are right
adjacent to the dwelling and you go to
the wealthy neighborhood you know if
somebody put up a billboard in the
middle of your gated community there
would be such an uprising that you know
it wouldn't wouldn't last the afternoon
so anyway people know what to protect
their own kids from to the extent that
the people who have the resources to
protect their kids from everything bad
are you know telling us what it is
that's harmful we shouldn't be allowing
those things near anybody's kids yeah
that's right next question you voiced so
this is written in telegraphic li4 to
save characters but I will try to read
it as if it's written in full words I
have you have voiced a sense of
hopelessness about reaching the whoa
Keys David fuller verbal wisdom says
he's focusing on having this
conversation without triggering the
immune response I want to suggest that
we take cues from Benjamin Boyce
especially in his recent episode with
the Union I don't know I'm not familiar
with that episode but obviously we're
familiar with Benjamin boys and with
David fuller real wisdom and that was
that's the question yeah
let's put it this way the experience of
trying to reach the truly woke is not a
positive one because even to the extent
that you can reach an individual it
doesn't last it's not durable because
they return to whatever milieu it is
that caused the the woke 'no sin the
first place there's undone although
there's maybe a little seed planted Oh
believe me I'm a big fan of the planning
the seed that can germinate later but
there's also a campaign to eradicate
those seeds socially the fact though is
maybe this is actually just the point
you were just making we have started to
hear often it comes in the form of an
apology which I must say I don't think I
need but people have started to contact
us and say I got it wrong I thought it
was just college campuses I thought you
were exaggerating now I see right mm-hmm
in the wake of the last three weeks yeah
and again I don't need an apology
especially if you're you know if you're
a big enough person to recognize that
you were wrong and actually say it to
somebody that you think you may have
discounted that's that's a big thing and
that's all that's necessary from my
perspective what what I would ask beyond
that is okay now that you've seen it
find your courage because you're gonna
need it right and with respect to the
woke it's not one level of woken us
right there are people who are rescue
able and the fact is to the extent that
we start bringing people over to the
side of reason then we have greater
leverage to access people who are more
deeply ensconced and so I do think most
of the people involved in this movement
are not aware of what they have signed
up with yeah
no I think that's right and I found just
just in the last couple of days I had
interactions with some people who I know
in a business relationship with you know
like a structural integration therapist
and a haircut or haircut or hairdresser
and someone else I can't remember so
people who I have iterative
relationships with I will see them again
I enjoy them very much but I don't know
them well they don't know me well and
it's easier especially for women on
average to just let the conversation go
and when someone says something that you
disagree with to to not disagree
especially right now right especially
given that we are all being expected to
adopt the new the new gods and not doing
so on my part with you know these people
who had already chosen to interact with
on the basis that they are reasonable
and honorable and not completely
ideological was still not the easiest
thing in the world but absolutely a
hundred percent worth doing and I I'm I
would say that everyone can do at least
that yeah everyone gonna do at least
that that when you when you hear someone
say something in what sounds like need
your support of say a movement or an
organization that you don't think is
what it appears giving a little nudge in
the direction of what you think can be
can be the thing necessary to change
people's minds and and just to open them
up to the possibility that what they've
been told isn't the full truth and maybe
not maybe
is not any of the truth in fact so what
I've said a number of times is that
there's actually a a thing you can train
yourself to do which is very rewarding
which is when you have an unbridgeable
gap figure out whether or not you can
cross it in other words there are some
gaps you probably can't cross but you
can practice the skill and the gaps you
can cross get bigger and bigger and it's
very rewarding when you get across them
so if we all took that approach we might
do much better yeah ok
this is this looks like a three-part
question I'll read it all and then see
where where we go back to hi you two
first simply thanks is there a societal
connectedness analog to Dunbar's number
we've gone from a small group of
primates to a global society but there
are no guarantees beyond that where is
our codes limit our carrying capacity
recent events caused me to wonder what
feedbacks exist within us that grow with
societal complexity undermining
pro-social behaviors for instance
cooperation in borrowing a compensatory
mechanism like swarming in bees we be on
the road to a collapse at best a second
Dark Ages at worst a weapons of mass
destruction fueled species level
existential crisis our wings are still
growing so there's no swarming off this
rock quite yet well I would say it's all
a question of hacking and clutching and
that there are things you know one of
the curious facts of modern life is that
people your television you know think
back to the 50s television in the living
room is a window into lives that are not
near you and you are a creature that is
not programmed to deal with the ability
to actually look in visually on a life
that isn't near you looking in as always
about proximity right you can describe a
life that's far away but it's not
realistic we come to view some of the
people on our screens as if we know them
and then now decades after this became
commonplace we are now getting to know
them and the fact is this relationship
isn't exactly a television relationship
right so we are finding mechanisms
rebuild our humanity to each other in a
way that actually is robust in the
meantime it has fragile elements and we
have to be very careful to protect it
and things breaking down into you know
clickbait discussions and things like
that is very hazardous but I think I
don't I don't I'm not without hope about
the process of us giving a damn about
each other I actually think that that
part can be done but we have to escape
the things that are built in to upset it
in order to get to a landscape where we
do feel that way this is actually one of
the things that livestream does as
opposed to recorded and played later
even for those who which is true for the
vast majority of people who end up for
instance watching these things that
we're doing the first missionary of
people who see them are not tuned in now
they're not watching them alive but for
those of you who are you know that we're
sitting here talking right now and that
brings us closer metaphorically and when
people watch it later they know that
there were there were more than just the
two of us participating here right now
even though you know we can't see your
chat we don't know what it is that
you're writing to each other right now
but we know it's happening and you know
we'll get a little feedback from our mod
afterwards as to how it went today but
you know mostly that's that's happening
beyond our ability to see but it's it is
creating a kind of community the way
that television piped end camp so
actually two things occur to me in this
light one if there was a difference on
Rogan this time to all the previous ones
which was that this time Rogan has
changed his podcast so that it is no
longer live and I must say I didn't even
think about it I thought it was a
trivial difference until he actually
started and because he starts
differently when it's live it was
immediately jarring to know that it was
just him and me in a room and that
there's this principle that I say to
people who are new to public life which
is you've got to remember the room is
not the room right the room is not the
room you are in a room with somebody but
the room maybe the internet or the world
and it may be people ten years in the
future if you say something now and it
gets brought up then
you have to be mindful of that and
Rogen's room that gap the gap between
the room you're in and the actual room
is the maximum gap yep exactly right it
couldn't be bigger couldn't be built it
there is no bigger at this point on
earth and there's almost no smaller it's
you and Joe and Jamie right or in the
case that you and I were on together
that you know the two of us and Joe and
Jamie it's a very small intimate room
that is outward looking to this gigantic
thing and there's there there's
something in tangibly different your
point about even if you arrived at this
video you know a week from now you know
that people were there live and that
means that they sort of proxy for your
reaction right
whereas knowing that it went out
afterwards and that it hit the internet
all at once it has a very different
different impact so yeah somehow we need
to think more carefully about how we
interface and start to bootstrap the
intimacy that we lost in the television
and early internet eras very good we
have a question from an editor of a
major magazine in Slovenia who would
like to get in touch with us Zack if you
would highlight that somehow so we can
try to get back to that what do you
think of the theory that Tsarskoe v2
originated in the Philippines I haven't
heard that theory hypothesis so yes
hypothesis is right I have not heard it
either I would love to know what it is
based upon yeah I need to don't I
wouldn't need to know more yeah let's
put it this way if it originated in the
Philippines then we need an explanation
of why it shows up in Wuhan in other
words what would have to be true for
that hypothesis to be likely is there
would have to be a sequence divergence
in a population of the virus early on in
the Philippines what we don't see in
Wuhan is the fumbling around that the
virus would be expected to do in its
early phase after it had jumped to
humans right well I mean unless unless
it was created the Philippines I moved
to Wuhan you mean well here's to you
talking about artificial oh I mean if
we're talking about it being
artificially created
all bets are off then yo could have been
created anywhere yeah well if it was
intentional right yes yes so anyway I
would say before we dig a hole any
deeper we got to figure out what this
hypothesis is based on and whether
there's anything to it but my guess is
probably probably it's just noise okay
so this person makes a statement and
then asked for our thoughts the
statement is animals seek and find
patterns whether they are there or not
this pattern is a T plus agent issah T
birth birthdays super moon this pattern
is a T plus agent issah T birthed
superstitions among humans give it
enough time other animals will to
inevitably adopt religions before
developing a [ __ ] meter that is like
our scientific method what are your
thoughts I think there's too much loaded
into the idea that superstitions
superstition is the pathological version
of something that is usually not
pathological it is the detection of
patterns whose explanation you don't
know but are nonetheless a useful
indicator of something you sure you mean
pathological it just seems a little
strong no I mean it okay I mean and I
don't maybe I don't mean it to have
connotations beyond that it is
maladaptive yeah lissa is the broken
version it's the broken versions that
become reified as as aphorisms when
they're wrong we call them superstitions
right and patterns that occur for
reasons you can't figure out but
nonetheless help you limit the search
area for something or something
something along those lines are usually
if nine times in ten what passes through
this machinery is productive and what is
amiss machinery no passes through the
whatever the proper or the intuition
component rather than the superstition
component nine nine times out of ten it
helps you one time out of ten it's
purely nonsense that's still a huge win
so in any case animals do have a
superstition this has been demonstrated
in chickens I believe
um where somebody basically set up a
conveyor belt on which I think it was
like rocks and corn were sent down in a
random sequence so they used a random
number generator to figure out whether
the next thing on the belt was gonna be
a rock or corn and patterns of course
exists there that don't mean anything
you know a random sequence will have
little patterns in it and the chickens
would pick up expectation which you
could tell they had by how long they
looked based on patterns that just
happened to be in the in the ya-ya
misapprehension of pattern that was
actually noise misapprehension of noise
into pattern and then changing future
behavior based on that yep
hypothesis coronavirus was released
intentionally by a single malevolent
individual most likely a lab employee he
or she just wanted to cause mayhem
similarly to high school shooters any
thoughts how likely is this to have
happened it is very difficult to rule
something like that out but I would say
absent evidence of it one can drive
themselves II let's put it this way in
general human beings behave semi
rationally which means that we can infer
something about why people do things
based on the fact that it would make
sense to do this and it wouldn't make
sense to do that and even things like a
school shooter school shooter maybe you
know there's always a question and this
has changed some of these shooters don't
die yeah event anymore what to change
histologic substantially but if somebody
is going to engage in mayhem that is
going to end their life there's always a
question about whether or not they had
decided to commit suicide first and then
decided to add some mayhem to it or if
they decided to commit some mayhem and
then accepted the loss of their life
those are two different kinds of events
that there's some fundamentally
different and they look interchangeable
on the outside yeah but nonetheless if
somebody decided to put their death to
thing that they found productive like
gaining fame or something like that it's
not it's obviously an insane behavior
but it is not incomprehensible well but
I mean I would say the one one other
thing that suggests against this with
the understanding that we just couldn't
know it's unlikely and we can't know but
that there's no element of of Fame here
the doing doing doing this kind of thing
anonymously actually is very rare truly
evil acts are themselves relatively rare
but they tend to come with a quest for
fame
yeah or resources so I've said you right
can't rule out the possibility that
somebody with you know no moral decency
and a desire to make money could have
set loose a pathogen knowing that it
would harm certain industries that they
could then short so anyway that's a very
frightening prospect and it's more
sensible than somebody anonymously
causing mayhem yep okay here's a
question are we from are you familiar
with Stephen L Talbott he's written to
many interesting articles on evolution
and his 1995 book the future does not
compute was a good warning on how
antisocial the internet would become I
am not familiar I don't think I am
either yeah I will highlight it Chad's
the capitol hill autonomous zone in
Seattle how long will it be permitted
are the authorities trying to force
Trump to send in the military shouldn't
POTUS do something when locals won't
there's been a murder there already how
long can this go on yeah there was a
double shooting last night I think one
of the people died I don't know what the
state of the other one is how long can
this go on you know here's the problem
we've got a damned if you do damned if
you don't situation and I would say
damned if you do is better I cannot
allow this to happen but I'm in the
second person this is actually our
friend Holly math nerd asking us the
second question here are the authorities
trying to force Trump to send in the
military that certainly gives them cover
if it's you know I don't remember who
the mayor in Seattle is I never do but
Inslee the governor of Washington
another I'm gonna go ahead and use your
term decrepit clown certainly wants
cover he'd really rather say that his
mean parents told him he had to then he
asked you because he's not gonna get a
he's gonna lose votes if he's the one to
crack down on this even though he
shouldn't yeah I should absolutely it's
absolutely 100% his job to crack down on
it but if he forces Trump to do
something and then he gets to complain
loudly about how Trump is overstepping
his authority even though this thing
needs to end then that potentially
frankly it's a it would solve Inslee's
immediate problem but it probably also
continues to feed to feed Trump more
more approval yep I think there are a
lot of games that could be played for
one thing in asleep as aspirations for
higher office or at least he did until
recently it's possible that the idea is
to get Trump to do something that will
be unpopular in certain places and will
shift votes the Biden or something I am
gonna push back on your use of the
reserved term decrepit clown because it
reppin no he's decrepit now and he's a
clown but I was he is a b-list decrepit
true yeah ballistic covered clown which
is in some ways did even harsher
criticism
oh it's harsher yeah you know less
decline you lift a decrepit clown yeah
that's good yeah very good we don't like
this guy no well he looked he hung us
out to dry yes he did he absolutely hung
us out to dry is the reason that we take
such a dim view of him yeah well also
that he's dim yeah he is dim yeah you
actually interacted with him right your
TED Talks on the panel with them no
wasn't TED talk it was a talk at
Evergreen
on the basically the Anthropocene and
what to think about it and he impressed
me as a total stuffed shirt that's what
Jeremy is yeah total stuffed shirt and
he gave a talk that was completely empty
and self congratulatory about how
Washington was leading the world towards
a green future all sorts of nonsense
yeah yeah he's got a lot of wishy-washy
stuff to say on climate change a
position that we have a lot of thoughts
on as well and I just wish that we had
better
there's on this front how dare he be the
guy that's like and I'm gonna be
carrying that flag yep
so ballistic rapid clown yeah excellent
how do we determine if the collateral
damage of the protests and/or local
culture is worth it we've been talking
the Black Panthers were necessary for
MLK to be more palatable what if all
this works it's really the second part
of that is not something I'd put
together that the the connection I what
you know one thing that immediately
jumps out at me here is we don't have I
mean we do have many people who could be
doing the work of MLK but what we have
at the moment is if this if this is
right this analogy is right the
equivalent of the Black Panthers taking
over and becoming the dominant voice and
it's not that they're covering for
something else like who are the voices
that are actually making making the
correct arguments for police reform and
you know lingering effects of racism in
the courts and such so I'm a little
troubled by this question because the
movement itself cannot mature into
something meaningful it is too convinced
of wrong things and what we are seeing
in the horizontal nosov it's exercises
of power the fact that it is toppling
institutions from within and causing
them to start
distributing kool-aid to the outside
world that that phenomenon can't be
turned off the people inside those
institutions are confused and they're
not going to become unconvincing has to
rein in their confusion even if
ultimately as I've been advocating as
loudly as I can even if we deal with the
fundamental I'm I can't even say
inequity anymore because they've robbed
us of the term equity but even if the
fundamental problems were to be
addressed the the force is not this mind
numbing
nihilist destructive destroyed George
Washington nonsense
yeah you know and go after you know we
didn't end up talking about black lives
matter today maybe we'll do so on
Tuesday but you know some of the some of
the principles that they have on their
website around things like going after
the nuclear family as if it's a
constructed Western artifact you know
it's suggested whoever wrote that and
you ever let that go up has never gone
anywhere else talked to anyone else
learned history thought about any other
species anything you do that the family
is a construct that needs to be
destroyed is actually a far more
egregious position than that all of the
founding fathers need to be canceled and
and that does seem to be what is being
argued so you know if that's one of the
founding principles here there's no good
that can come of it this movement as
currently constituted has no capacity to
build and actually the failure of the
Chas which is now the chop oh yeah
yes we stand for Capitol Hill occupied
protest which doesn't even make sense
and then I protest Capitol Hill there at
chop could mean two things they can't
even get an acronym so they've got an
acronym that they are in fighting about
what it means right as people are being
killed yeah you want to put up that
webpage that's a Wikipedia page yeah
yeah
no capitol hill autonomous own yeah we
can't that's too small for us to oh
there it is yep it's also known as free
Capitol Hill and referred to as the
Capitol Hill organized protest and the
Capitol Hill occupied protest so if you
can't get your acronym straight so that
there are four terms running around for
exactly the same location and people are
being shot there's a pretty good chance
you don't really know how civilization
works and you're not the people to whom
it should be handed over this is this is
one of the things that happens when you
abandon the idea of leaders and this is
you know what what you've talked about
now and Joe Rogan and elsewhere and and
here this is what you saw what we saw
but do you saw more intimately with
occupy yeah that from the beginning it
was understood to be leaderless by
intention but the leader lessness was of
course gamed as it will always will be
as it always will be so the final answer
to that question though is the movement
cannot build the movement however is
scaring the crap out of people so that
they may be ready to hear something that
many could not hear before and so to the
extent that a bunch of us are scrambling
trying to point out what the actual
meaning of this moment is and what needs
to happen in order to prevent us from
sliding into a Maoist takeover which to
which we seem to be headed that might
open the door to positive change and I
am loathe to give credit to people who
have threatened the foundations of
civilization in order to move things but
if we get there I guess we can fight
about how to how to address the history
yeah okay we're gonna do two more
questions from this and then switch to
the other the super chat from the
current livestream this one is a
two-part question you've consistently
described elements of the protest as
Maoist are you aware that Steve ban and
other and others like him are used in
the exact same term second question in
describing protests as Maoist what
incentive do protesters and sympathizers
have to listen with an open mind to your
perspective how does it encourage
rational engagement our compromise so to
the first question I didn't know that
Steve Bannon and others like him
whatever that means exactly are using
the exact same term
and I'm no fan of Steve Bannon but it
doesn't matter it does it doesn't matter
if people who are actually you know
hateful and I'm not saying that Steve
Bannon is but you know it doesn't matter
if people who are completely hateful
come to the same conclusion that you are
that does not render your conclusion
false well and you know if you're going
to behave in a Maoist fashion and the
problem is we're left grasping for
alternatives it's so Maoist it's so you
know struggle sessions have emerged we
need to invent some other personal
euphemism that Steve Bannon won't have
heard of in order that he won't settle
on the same formulation it's not you
know history history doesn't repeat
itself but it it works right so you know
do we have a red guard not exactly you
know is it is it exactly to a pert you
know to it to a detail struggle sessions
no but you know of all of the possible
comparisons and we we listed a few of
them actually in our Washington Examiner
article in 2017 after Evergreen blew up
the weird that you know the 4500 words
the longest piece that we've written
about what happened at Evergreen far
from complete but you know we started I
think by saying you know is it is this
that you cut out the Jacobins is this
the French Revolution is the brown
shirts is this the Cultural Revolution
not exactly any of them but a little bit
of each and really the closest one that
I've seen and you know either of us are
historians and I'm sure we're missing a
lot of detail here but is the Cultural
Revolution but this looks like China in
the 60s and to the extent that there's a
question about does this lead to
openness on the part of those behaving
this way to hearing what we have to say
my hope actually I don't think most of
them know anything about the Red Guard
they don't know anything about the Great
Leap Forward the Cultural Revolution and
to the extent that they start hearing an
accusation that they can't feel because
they don't know anything about it maybe
they'll look it up and they will notice
their own behavior matching this thing
and they'll think that's odd mm-hmm I
don't want to live that way why am i
behaving in this fashion now I'm not
expecting that to wash over them but to
the extent that one could plant a seed
that got them to look up something
useful the parallel is too close to be
ignored and you can't really
I mean we get into this too with you
know the lab leak hypothesis
Trump has politicized the idea that
maybe this came from the Institute of
virality what are we to do not talk
about it because Trump has some thing
that overlaps sort of with what we're
saying this is anti science yes is this
is dismissing ideas on the basis that
someone else who believes it is is
hateful or antithetical to the cause
that you believe in this is this is
explicitly anti-scientific i will say
that in the last couple of weeks i asked
some friends for their suggestions as to
how to learn more about the cultural
revolution because i read a bit decades
ago when i was in high school in college
and really haven't gone back recently so
as you as you know i've got this pile of
books now waiting for me to dig in and
you know i I've poked in a few places
and it's hard not to act as a
verification ax straight it's hard not
to just see the confirming examples and
I'm trying to do the falsification a
thing that we always try to do but so
far and I'm not very far into any of
them I am I am more affirmed in my sense
that this looks more like China in the
sixties than any of these other examples
that we have yeah and I think it's it's
good that you've got the books and I
think we know they're not gonna burn
themselves so certainly hope not
self-immolating books great hey that's a
thing oh yay okay one more from this
live stream then I will switch the next
one what do you think about youth sports
commencing kids need a lot of activity
and seem relatively safe from severe
cases could also help get them more
vitamin D yeah III think this should be
happening and there is risk there's more
risk than if the kids are just hanging
out alone it is but I think that risk is
pretty low you know I put the school
near us that we take walks up to with a
dog and sometimes play speed mitten and
such in the in the field there the
playground is just it's heartbreaking
you see single kids
you know throwing a basketball into the
hoop and and the play structures
themselves for the younger kids are
roped off with caution tape and you know
the the playgrounds isn't about youth
sports but I know that our youngest a
younger son in particular would so
benefit from being able to run around in
a coordinated fashion and and and play
and engage physically with other people
that this would be a huge boon and does
it come with risk yeah but I think the
risk is low yep I think the real risk is
the downstream the kids seem to be
relatively safe even when they get the
infection and the likelihood of getting
the infection outdoor during the day I
would say maybe limit the you know
competitive play two times from the sun
is shining because you know then you've
got the benefit of the UV but there's
also other things that you can do that
aren't organized sports that would have
almost no risk and so anyway I will end
up talking more about this device later
but if you have the resources you might
get your kids electric unicycles and
they could go learn them and that'll
occupy them for a month or two as
they're learning it and then they can go
adventure and the thing is it's a very
high volume of air that passes by you so
you can have fun with other people
without being right up in their faces
and there's also I think you've heard a
bit a bicycle that's like - yeah yeah
bicycle is a good one - yeah so that's
an oldie but a goodie yeah indeed okay
and there were many lovely comments in
the last in the last super chat as well
that we didn't get to first one in the
next I - like shaggy dog stories tell us
about the knife in the back corner the
knife in the back corner is a handmade
knife by a friend of ours he is a
current who is a swordsmith it is either
I don't know is it I'm going to butcher
this and then I'm gonna be in trouble
yeah is it Valyrian steel or Damascus
steel which one of those is a real thing
yeah Dave if you're watching Davis know
Dave is now shaking his fist
yeah at the screen the only made the the
darkhorse logo the logo I added the LEDs
but anyway yes
so thanks Dave for the cool knife and
yeah we don't have we don't have a story
beyond that right yeah no it's just a
knife that he made with us in mind and
and we love it and it's really cool I
don't know if you can see the layering
of the steel can you see the layering of
the steel oh yeah yeah yeah it's a
really nice knife cool okay next
question
Hale professors do you think the
orienting reflux plays a role in how
folks interact on the Internet
I believe it was a Russian psychologist
that professor Peterson referenced in
his first book who discovered it I am
not familiar with the orienting reflex
and I have also not read Jordan's first
book yeah I should have so I don't know
it do you know what neither sorry I have
a solution for cyclical poverty pay
people government program do not have
kids until they are 18 years old pay
parents to enter the program pay kids at
18 to 28 della payment for higher ed
completion reward marriage with kids so
there's some pieces in there I don't
quite get but it's a it's incentivizing
you know incentivizing not having kids
young and I think you know I think
financial incentives to to engage in
behavior that is societally beneficial
has a long history it is sometimes
troubled but it often works and I don't
think there's anything wrong with it in
theory and something like this could
work what is the joke there's no joke
it's a very sad moment the problem is
that a proposal like that which I don't
know about the details of the proposal
but the basic idea is that we should
incentivize the behavior that we think
is valuable and unfortunately this is
why BLM has taken up arms against a
nuclear family rendering this proposal
racist mmm so the question is how can we
bootstrap our way out of the little trap
that's been set for us where we can
start to talk about what's actually good
and
get it to more people yeah so that's the
puzzle but anyway the idea of incentives
to lead us in the direction of things
that are actually beneficial of course
mm-hmm all right we get pick the one you
like most we got three options and four
different questions pick the one you
like most one so we're gonna answer one
of these questions okay idea does
globalization make us vulnerable to
invasive species like ideas mind viruses
if you will and how do we incentivize
info businesses to localize for now
trying to get most users is the only
winning strategy it's one option to
should we want healthy competition among
nations and if so how do we make it
happen three let's steal man the rule
all whites should be considered racist
properly I guess you know about false
positives and false negatives so which
one of those do you want to take on the
first one yeah okay so let me just
repeat it does globalization make us
vulnerable to invasive species like
ideas maybe mind viruses and how do we
incentivize info businesses to localize
for now trying to get the most users is
the only winning strategy yeah there's
definitely a problem it is actually a
challenge to something I have sadly
advocated which is that maybe it is time
for us to have a global language that
the danger of speaking languages that
are distinct and therefore
miscommunicating or having lower
precision communication when something
important is at stake is something we
can no longer afford and the fact of
plugging us all into the same language
is obviously going to make the invasive
idea problem worse yeah on the other
hand it's harder to hide I think we do
know the solution to invasive bad ideas
the solution is high quality critical
thinking skills and we do a really
terrible job of passing these on even in
the good neighborhoods we don't teach
this all right we teach something much
more mundane much more targeted at
turning people into cogs to operate
machines that we frankly no longer even
use maybe especially in some ways
because in the so-called good
neighborhoods the education is still
pretty crappy yep private schools being
partial exception but at least in
neighborhoods that are you know I'm
frankly more dangerous kids end up with
some street smarts
they end up knowing some things about
how things operate in a way that frankly
the pretty privileged kids who are
mostly behind the riots and speaking on
behalf of a bunch of people who they
mostly have never met don't know
anything about yeah it's mostly led by
people who actually don't have the life
experience of knowing either critical
thinking or actually like physical
engagement with the world and form of a
craft or something yeah so we should be
doing a lot more physical skills in
education where and this has been a
mantra for for both of us where there is
no judgment necessary on the part of a
human being
in order to figure out whether you have
succeeded or failed Yeah right
when you're juggling you know if you've
dropped the balls right it's not it's
not a judgment call so engagement with
those kinds of skills teaches the mind
to think and teaching the mind to think
is like teaching it to spot
nice-sounding wrong ideas and if there's
one reason to be absolutely frightened
of what's taking place in our streets
it's the impression that the people who
are telling us what needs to happen next
do not have the basics with respect to
understanding what might work and what
will definitely not yeah one more thing
on this question I do think picking up
on your point about a global language
you know it's never it's never set right
with me I know it doesn't sit right with
you either you've advocated it how you
don't you don't like it
one-one cost of it that I hadn't really
considered is that it does make outposts
more difficult places where interesting
ideas can hide and people can not be
exposed to bad ideas but also hide out
and discuss you know discuss the values
that are coming in and sort of wall
themselves off and you know it's as
people who have loved exploring a lot of
the
world both through doing our research
and through just just traveling
certainly the fact of people speaking
different languages has been often more
often a barrier than something alluring
is neither of us are particularly adept
in picking up new languages
whereas making friends with a little bit
of language and experiencing food and
different cultural events think that's
all of you super easy and wonderful and
for us and it's one of the values of of
travel but language in part because it
does keep us separate is also therefore
protective
multiple languages yep I agree there's a
trade off yeah Brett you said it would
be hard for you and Sam Harris to do
psychedelics together dude it would be
for anybody who was with us yeah yeah
that question came about someone asked
if you and me and Sam Harris and Jordan
Peterson would consider doing doing
psychedelics together to address the
problems of the world and I think we
arrived at like hopefully Jordan I can
go hang out and talk because you and say
we're gonna be doing something that we
don't want to so the second part the
question is do you two have some
disagreements or things to work out we
have I think a very small number of very
significant disagreements that
unfortunately haunt all of the stuff on
which we might otherwise make progress
so I'd actually like to solve that
problem yeah but you know no I just
think I I don't know I've never seen Sam
on psychedelics but I have the sense
that the two of you would become
wall-like and not getting anywhere with
each other
yes it would be frankly more frustrating
for the other people in the room but
maybe for you you might you might have
grateful to say actually it would depend
a lot on what psychedelic often yes no I
mean it just makes a difference yangyang
we're told I'm all right yeah I do you
want to say anything about having put
forth the Dark Horse duo hypothesis on
Rogan having done so here in episode 19
yes
any of you will have been around for
episode nineteen and have watched our
stream fail spectacularly on the mention
of William McRaven but in any case I
advanced the Dark Horse duo plan
separate from the people who I proposed
as the inhabitants of the plan on Joe
Rogan and I have seen a ton of really
positive feedback I'm very heartened
people are energized by the idea I think
they even though we didn't talk that
much about what problems it solves they
seem to intuit what problems it solves
and so anyway I think the hard part is
that we actually have to draft either
these two people or other people into
the proposal there aren't that many
people who would be good I think these
are the right two people if they will do
it but they're not going to sign on to a
plan that is a Hail Mary it has to have
public pressure so that they know
they're not going to be left hung out to
dry by you know quixotic you know run
against the major party candidates so
they're you know no one with actual
reach is going to engage in something
that seems like tilting at windmills
right to use your reference nor should
they
it has to be credible which means it has
to have public pressure behind it and I
think it should and anyway we can say
more about it later but keep the
pressure going and spread the word and
if we can persuade them I mean here's
the here's the key come November we
could all feel so much better we could
know that we're turning the corner right
November isn't that far off and if we
elect Trump or Biden then we're looking
at four more years of the same madness
and frankly let's I don't know though I
don't know that we can survive it
they are a list decrepit clowns
absolutely a very Plus list Agrippa
class
like for Echo asks like for telomeres do
lab animals have lower vitamin D than in
the wild
does ko vat19 being more severe for
people with low vitamin D suggests that
it's been selected for through
gain-of-function research in lab animals
oh I caught the beginning of that
interesting
maybe I mean I think you know really why
wouldn't lab animals have lower vitamin
D than in the wild of course they would
unless they're being supplemented
tremendously and even so supplements are
not the same as getting it through
synthesizing it from sunlight so this
this strikes me is a very interesting
question excellent question
yeah I don't know what the situation is
with other creatures especially furry
creatures right vitamin D on their nose
well nor do I know what happens with
human cells that are not part of a human
I don't know what these tissues are if
these tissues are basically vitamin D
deficient inherently yeah any way would
be worth knowing yeah if some if
somebody out there knows please point us
in the right direction
Bret Bret Weinstein of soap know at its
support at Bret Weinstein dotnet that's
it that's it is it useful to model bad
behavior to be fined bad behavior as the
category of mind viruses that can invade
our societies or institutions would it
help to make people more conscious of
the danger behaving badly in society I'm
not sure what the question means yeah
I'm not sure is it useful to model bad
behavior is the category of mind viruses
that can invade our society is it useful
to think of bad behavior maybe that's
what I mean okay as the category of mind
viruses that can invade our societies or
institutions that's not perfect because
you know anything success doesn't
inherently make you bad so there you
know there are bad things that can be
successful and good things as well yeah
I would say the problem is that most
often what you're looking at is
something that serves the individual or
some small entity at cost
to the larger population that spreads
because of that conflict which is not
really virus like unless you think of it
almost makes the individual virus like
it's not a perfect analogy
so there are truly bad ideas that are
kind of contagious like I've got if I
say Pokemon go are we gonna lose half
the people who listen it's okay um you
know playing Pokemon go that's not good
for you at expense to society it's bad
for everybody involved and addictive
right so that's kind of my envira see
why is the boy I don't know this term
maybe you do Brett the Gini coefficient
why is the Gini coefficient it's it's
this one
yeah I see why is the Gini coefficient
not part of the conversation even though
it explains clearly the inequality that
inequality is the root of crime the West
is the 1% of the world but we only see
what's close to us thank you
I'm trying to remember what that
coefficient is and without it I'm not
gonna be able to answer this question
you know what we're gonna I'm gonna put
this at the top but yeah well we'll come
back to this at the beginning of the
queue and I next time if you would
highlight it Zach that'd be great
Bretton Heather actually we're will be
doing on time all right so we're gonna
get a couple more of these try to get
through a few more of these Bretton hey
there how do you feel about hashtag
citizen science-based you bi blockchain
orgs like curecoin demonstrated it 300
science projects away incentives sort of
falls out there do you know much about
this a little bit I mean the hashtag
with us about it let's put it to you
this way it's the right idea the you
know to bootstrap some mechanism that
can think straight by being independent
of the corrupt institutions is the right
idea
some kind of crypto currency connection
that allows this thing to get funded the
right idea
also anyway it's one of a number of
projects that has that basic framework
and I have got some people lined up to
come on the podcast to talk about their
version which is not inherently science
oriented although I see
no reason that it could not be utilized
for it
so anyway an upcoming episode we'll have
that discussion wonderful
Trump has publicly gathered black
leaders to talk and enact realistic
reforms as Brett said he would do do you
believe do you believe your own
political biases are keeping you from
seeing Trump's moderate solutions I
don't know that to have happened I
believe that would be a crazy thing to
just flat-out assert and not be true
yeah I just might know who is on the
list that'll tell us whether or not this
is a serious effort or not I don't think
I do ignore Trump's moderate instincts I
think I spend a lot of time trying to
not fault him for things that are not
fault worthy right there's a lot that's
fault worthy that's the problem but I do
not go into this with any assumption as
those who are longtime Watchers will
know I was rooting for him I certainly
didn't vote for him but at the point
that he was in office my feeling is
whoever has been elected you should root
for them to succeed and to make things
better even if it makes you look foolish
we managed to have hope said you know
what he's in it maybe the only maybe
he'll pull off the course as it were you
know to be you know he was so political
yeah that he could get in even though he
was a complete outsider and now that
he's in maybe he can actually do the
reform that he talked about but there
seems to have been precious little swamp
draining yeah I thought he had he had
room having accomplished what he did
which nobody else could of or almost
nobody else could have he had room to be
the greatest president in history he
could have refunded the nation but it
doesn't over the first time you said
that to me it's like are you kidding me
but you know I'm just saying if you
could have swapped in another person
yeah right at that moment in his cards
they could have refounded the knife he
had marbles he didn't he created many of
them yeah like you know more power to
him that he did but then then what'd he
do with him but you know there are
trade-offs and the problem is that the
skills that were necessary to get
through the gate are not consistent with
the instincts that would cause you to go
through that refounding process and that
it he's too good at politics to put it
aside I mean it
basically what he is good at and so
everything is political so my guess is
even if he has brought people together
he will not be able to resist using it
as a political weapon but please mr.
president
prove me wrong hmm yeah right let's do
two more
previously you talked about
post-modernism versus Marxism and trying
to explain identitarian ISM aren't Gramm
she they can prancing that correctly and
the Frankfurt School the connecting
point using critical theory and to
undermine bourgeois values and so on
yeah and so we've actually gotten some
private communications objecting to our
dismissing critical theory and and
specifically Mark Hughes which we talked
about in one of the most recent ones in
answering a question but yes the
Frankfurt School seems to be
foundational and the connecting point
and while both of us have been up to
speed on all the intricacies here I
certainly am NOT at the moment and I
don't know that you are at the moment to
speak to all the different ways the
connections do and do not track to the
current moment I am absolutely up to
speed on all of the connections and I
would like to diagram them for you now
okay no let me say this I actually think
this is a mistake which trying to do
what the questioner is asking us to do
here's my point this is this is your
magic right here well no no no in a good
way like this is this is the Gordian
knot stuff that you do so well we are in
a phase in which all sorts of people
have some sort of a dog in the fight
somewhere on the level of theory right
you've got anarchists who are freaking
out that they are being synonymous with
an teefin though an Tifa if you look
closely is basically an anarchist
organization and says so so what I would
say is do not mind the details they
don't matter this isn't going to be
exactly any of these things does this
movement loosely match the archetype of
an anarchist movement it does own it
that's what it is right is this a
question of the Frankfurt School sorta
but most of the people in the street
wouldn't know what the Frankfurt School
is and you know is this more like you
know the cultural revolution than it is
like the Bolshevik Revolution well so
far does it have elements of the French
Revolution
it does is it going to be like any of
these things no you already know that
right it's gonna be new so the question
really the question I was actually
trying to convince my parents was the
right question when I saw them in LA was
is what's going on now is it going to be
on the same list as the Bolshevik
Revolution the Cultural Revolution the
French Revolution Cambodia Nazi
Germany's gonna be on that list if so
that's all you need to know you know
what that force is and the question is
do you have some way to deal with it or
is getting out of its way the most you
can hope for right if it's if it belongs
on that list that's good enough you
don't need to parse the details anywhere
you're gonna drive yourself crazy and
you're gonna waste effort that is at
this moment it's so precious so don't
bother just accept that these things are
loosely enough right there they don't
have to be precise they have to be
accurate and if they are accurate we
know enough about what comes next that
we should go there yeah you did it all
right excellent
last question the current left seems to
be a product of the 1960s how I left how
I left which intended to liberate
customs and ideas from a restrictive
Society became restrictive in its own
towards politically incorrect ideas did
it become part of the establishment yeah
actually it did it did in part become
part of the establishment and this is I
mean this is a point that that we've
been making for years since before
Evergreen blew up really that in part
liberals should be celebrating and
recognized for the fact that many of the
things that they before our time but you
know we were fighting for with regard to
actual civil rights
and you know second wave feminism not
the later waves but you know and and you
know just equality of opportunity for
people regardless of demographics and
you know and things like restricted
working hours and child labor laws like
all of these are actually wins for
liberals who became the establishment to
some degree they became the
establishment becoming the establishment
makes you conservative unless you have a
very great strength of character and I
don't mean that conservatives don't have
strength of character but what I mean is
that when you have a lot to lose your
tendency to want to conserve the things
that got it for you is so high that you
don't necessarily update when you should
so that process has as I think I did a
pretty good job on Joe Rogan's program
of explaining that process is frozen
normal regular folks out of a lot of the
well-being that society generates and
they're pissed and that's why they're in
the street and they're not wrong
it is rigged against them and it's not
evenly rigged it's rigged against some
populations more than others which
explains the sort of fusion of occupy
with black lives matter but the point
also though and the point also is
intersectionality is a new solution to
an old problem and unfortunately the old
problem is when you don't have growth to
offer people who are demanding growth
when growth makes us feel good because
things are getting better alright and
you don't have any growth to offer them
you figure out how you can get some
phony growth and you can get phony
growth in a number of ways you can steal
it from the future and make the future
worse in order to make the present feel
better or you can steal it from people
who can't defend themselves so we've got
a demographic problem in which corrupt
elites in both parties are not sharing
well-being that they have earned through
what Tim Rupp would call money on money
returns what I would say rent-seeking
but those people are not ready to share
and instead of sharing what they've
decided to do is take people who are
aggrieved and point them at people who
can't
themselves it's not that different from
what happened in Weimar Germany blaming
the Jews justified stealing stuff from
them and giving it to other people who
wanted growth and the German apparatus
couldn't provide it right so this is an
old trick now in this case the
intersectional version is new the
intersectional version says you can take
it from white people because they
deserve it that's what it is
and the point is that's cheaper than
sharing I know my sister-in-law makes a
point like this I've been making that
point for a very long time
that instead of sharing what has been
hoarded you can point people at other
people they're now allowed to steal from
and you know I mean you can just take
that sentence and map it onto all of the
things that we are now told are
desirable why would you get get rid of
the police well certainly going to allow
you to steal from people you've now been
told you're entitled to steal from right
it's not that complicated
so is that the revolution you want sure
as hell ain't the one I want and we're
done all right well we seem to have
survived that's good anyway we are alive
which is one of the things about
survival India tends to leave it that
way
all right so we'll be back on on Tuesday
and you may put another podcast up in
the interim you want to say anything
about that yet nope you okay stay this
channel you definitely want to subscribe
so that you are alerted when new things
drop on this channel and there are some
great ones coming yep and if you want
access to a private Q&A join my patreon
at one of the levels where you can
either ask a question or just be invited
to participate and what else what else
oh maybe that's it we'll see you Tuesday
happy solstice all right be well
everyone
you